Uncle Noel? Yeah? Do you know
what week it is this week?
It's Bread Week - Paul's favourite.
Do you wanna see something amazing?
Yes, please.
I was messing about in Paul's
dressing room last night
and I found this. Check this out.
It's the Hollywood handshake. Wow!
Shall we try it out?
Yes, please, actually.
I'll be Paul. Thank you.
Really like your baps.
Thank you, actually.
It's too powerful! Too powerful.
Hi, guys. You all right?
All right?
You haven't been playing
with my handshake, have you?
No, Mr Hollywood.
What handshake?
Because if you have
you get this...
..right?
Welcome to
The Great British Bake Off.
Last time...
..it was biscuit week.
I went to art school for this.
If I rubbed them,
I'd wish for Star Baker.
Dave conjured up
a spectacular showstopper.
That is remarkable.
And his Star Baker wish was granted.
Oh, it's cracked.
Rowan was all at sea.
It's definitely been in a storm,
this pot.
But in the end, it was Mak...
I know, it's not brilliant.
I just think the whole thing's
just a little bit clumsy.
..who had to walk the plank.
I'm gonna miss you.
Now... Whack it.
..the bakers face trial by bread.
It's a shame that
Paul Hollywood's judging it, eh?
A soda bread signature.
Interesting flavours.
A Technicolour Technical.
You're a Smurf, aren't you?
Yes.
And a Showstopper Challenge
where transforming dough...
I'm not very good at plaiting.
..into intricate bread plaques...
Might be ready in time to bake.
I hope so.
..will push the bakers...
Don't drop it, don't drop it,
don't drop it. ..to their limits.
It's not funny!
Yuck.
Bread's the one area I've probably
got more experience in,
but am I confident? I don't know.
Bread is something that
I've had to teach myself for this.
I kind of wish I hadn't practised,
to be honest.
I felt more confident before.
I like making bread at home
in my kitchen with music on,
but under the eyes
of Paul Hollywood...bit scary.
You have to laugh about it,
because we all dreading it.
Hello, bakers,
welcome back to the tent.
It's time for
your Signature Challenge.
Today, the judges would like you to
make two beautifully baked
soda bread loaves.
Now, you may flavour your
soda breads any way you like,
but one should be sweet
and one should be savoury.
Also, your loaves should be baked
freeform rather than in a tin.
What do you mean, freeform?
Just floating in the air? Yes.
And the judges would like you
each to make a butter
to go with your breads.
Blimey, they don't want much,
do they?
You have one hours, 45 minute.
On your marks. Get set. Bake.
OK, let's go.
Feeling good and ready to go.
I'm excited about soda breads.
I had a lot of it.
My granny used to make
a soda bread every day.
I hope I do a good job with it.
As opposed to a slow prove
with yeasted breads,
the chemical raising agents
in soda breads
starts work almost immediately.
And bicarb into my mixture.
So they must get their loaves
into the oven as quickly as possible
in order to achieve the rise
the judges are after.
Cream of tartar. I'm not sure
what it's doing in my recipe.
I'm sure it plays a role.
The thing is with this challenge,
it's only an hour
and three quarters.
They haven't got to deal with
yeast but they've gotta deal with
the reaction between
the rising agents
and milk or buttermilk to
create the growth in the loaf.
We've asked our bakers to make
two soda breads,
one sweet and one savoury.
Do you know, I'm expecting
lots of cheese and lots of herbs
and lots of nuts.
It would be really nice
to find somebody using something
really different.
Za'atar is more like
an aromatic spice.
Traditionally we have it
like in pastries, on top of breads
so it's perfect for this.
I think they'll all be nervous
because it's their first time
Bread Week with me,
but I think I've given them
an easy challenge. It's soda bread.
Listen to me, Paul Hollywood,
I want to talk to you about bread.
You go on about bread
and you go on about bread.
No-one under the age of 40
eats bread any more.
OK?
Morning. Hello, morning.
Morning. Hello.
So Mark, tell us about
your soda bread.
My, uh, savoury soda bread
is a sobrasada
and an Irish sheep smoked cheese
and then my sweet soda bread
is a Irish stout and chocolate.
So you're baking for Ireland today?
I am, yes. I have the weight
of a nation on my shoulders.
Are you Irish? I am, yeah.
I'm joking.
Hello, Mark speaking.
Mark loves to travel in his job
as a project manager
for public health research programs
in developing countries.
He's adding Spanish sausage,
honey, and mature Cheddar
to his savoury soda bread, but in
a nod to his Northern Irish roots
will blend the chocolate in his
sweet loaf with a classic stout.
And what's the liquid
you're putting in there?
Some melted butter and honey.
Honey in both.
Interesting. No buttermilk?
And buttermilk sorry, yeah,
of course. I was gonna say.
Of course buttermilk.
This is a tip
going through the competition.
When he says "interesting",
that means you've done it wrong.
Done it wrong? OK, OK.
Along with Mark,
three other bakers are using
a location as their inspiration.
I lived in Chester
for a little while
and I used to love
the Welsh bara brith
so I've based my sweet one
on that bara brith flavour,
which is just like a bread pud,
in a sense.
East Sussex-based Linda loves to
head to Bexhill beach
to fish for mackerel and mullet
which she can throw on the barbie.
Hey!
Chilli, cheese and coriander will
flavour Linda's savoury bread
while her love for
traditional Welsh tea cakes
has inspired her sweet loaf.
Lots of fruit in it. Mm-hmm, nice.
I've soaked my fruit in brandies.
Ooh!
I'm like one of those '80s,
uh, game-show hosts.
Say something else.
Pepped it up a little bit.
Oo-er!
I could do this all day.
Rowan's creativity has been sparked
from a little further afield.
This is the salsiccia,
the Italian sausage.
So just get it fried off
in a moment.
Get a quick start.
When he's not baking,
Rowan loves to spend time
in his Worcestershire garden.
That one's rosa mundi. OK.
Uh, which is Latin,
rose of the world.
Rowan's bakes include southern
Italian sausage, fennel and olives
for his savoury loaf,
and northern Italian polenta
with raisins and honey
for his sweet loaf.
It's quite a lot, isn't it?
It is. There's a lot going on.
There's a shock.
I just hope they work
in combination. I think they do so.
When you say polenta
you've got in there.
Yeah. What's the polenta
to the flour mix?
370g of polenta and 130 flour.
So it is quite gritty.
It's a risky one.
Some people don't like the
grittiness - I rather like it.
OK, thank you very much.
Interesting. Good luck, Rowan!
Thanks.
Marc's inspiration
comes from shores closer to home.
So I'm doing a Cornish-themed
soda bread
so I'm using Cornish Kern.
It's based on the Cornish Yarg.
It's quite strong, actually,
but not overpowering
so I thought it might
work well for this.
Get a bit of flour.
Born and raised in Leicester,
adopted Cornishman Marc
loves baking with his daughters.
Great. Fist bumps.
To cope with the pressure
of baking bread in the tent,
Marc is keen to keep things familiar
by including as many Cornish
ingredients as possible.
So I'm doing a Cornish kelp,
Cornish cheese,
Cornish sea salt and Cornish cream.
Covered in buttermilk!
It's not funny!
Yeah, I'm all right,
I'm carrying on. Yuck.
So the bicarb
will react with the buttermilk
and is what causes your soda bread
to rise.
The bakers need to ensure
their chosen flavours
work alongside the soft,
cakey dough.
I'm gonna be trying to get
the black pudding
as well-distributed
within the bread as possible.
Any additional moisture or fat could
inhibit the rise of the soda bread
or prevent it from baking through
properly.
There's a lot of chopping
going on today.
When it comes to her ingredients,
Hermine isn't playing it safe.
I was trying to be
a bit adventurous.
I thought I'd try salmon
and cheese.
I don't even know
if that's a combination.
When she's not combining her
job as an accountant
with being a single mother
to son Stephen...
Oh, ooh, sorry.
..Hermine enjoys a spot of knitting.
Another scarf for Stephen.
Hopefully it will be ready
for winter.
She'll be hoping her salmon and
cheese flavours knit together well
alongside her sweet loaf of dried
fruits soaked in orange liqueur.
How much salmon have you got
going in? I've got 180 gram.
How have you gone with practice?
It's been all right, yes.
There was a bit of dread
in your face then.
And Hermine's not the only baker
taking a risk
with their ingredients.
With za'atar,
it's quite an overpowering flavour
if you allow it to be.
When I was trying to make
the recipes I was asking my dad,
I was like, "What should I do?"
And he goes, "Well, you make
a really good Turkish pide,"
and I always put za'atar
on top of it for him.
He was like, "Why don't you
put that in your bread?"
So I was like, this is for my dad.
And it's not just Dad
giving out advice.
Hospital pharmacist Sura
grew up surrounded by a family
of women who loved to cook.
Fond of incorporating her heritage
into her bakes,
she'll be hoping
Middle Eastern flavours of za'atar,
olive and dried fruits will impress.
Are you confident?
Uh, quietly confident.
Look - he's trying to break you
but he can't, can't do it.
I know - that's why I don't look
in his eyes. Too powerful.
No-one can look into those eyes.
They'll turn to stone, right?
Yeah, they turn to baking flour.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Are you sure about that? No.
I don't have a watch, do you? No.
Just get that feeling though,
don't you,
that they're halfway through. Yes.
Interesting flavours.
Hopefully they'll like it.
Once their ingredients have been
introduced to the dough...
Texture's reasonable.
..the bakers can begin delicately
shaping their breads.
Just try and bring it together
as much as possible
without overworking it.
Too much kneading will result in
dense, unrisen loaves.
Want to make it smooth but make sure
that I'm not handling it too much.
I'm just cutting the bread -
kind of lets it all puff up nicely.
It lets it cook through better
plus it's just a nice little bit
of decoration.
It's in the oven at 200 degrees
for 30 minutes.
One down.
Right, I'm using a pizza stone
which I've brought from home.
If you use a pizza stone, you get
a more even heat distribution
and it also gives
a really nice crusty bottom.
Laura likes to put her pizza stone
to good use
at home with her husband Matt.
You're king of the pizzas - I'll
stick to the baking. I'm pizza king.
Laura's aiming for bold flavours
for both of her soda breads,
tweaked from family recipes.
The sweet bread,
it's sort of based on
my Nana Peg's scones that she does.
Soda bread's kind of like a scone.
So I'm kind of doing this one
as like a bit of a tribute to her.
And so I've just made my marzipan.
I've found that when I put it in
in lumps
it kind of goes very stodgy
so I'm gonna grate it in.
Pretty sure this is
a new technique Paul's gonna hate.
So I'm making my sweet soda bread
now,
so I'm just crumbling the butter
into the flours and sugar -
gives it more of a scone-like
texture.
I mean, who makes sweet sofa bread?
What is that?
I am making it today,
but it's not my finest work.
It's a shame that Paul Hollywood's
judging it, eh?
Cheers.
When she's looking to unwind,
Lottie likes to relax on the beach
with friends and family.
Long summer afternoons
are Lottie's inspiration
for her savoury summertime soda,
while her sweet ingredients
are inspired by her favourite
breakfast of blueberry pancakes.
How are the blueberries going in?
Well, they're going in whole.
How many are you putting in?
Only 60g.
So much how flour? 350.
OK. Love that face. That's great.
Maybe less, even. Less?
Maybe none.
Maybe...no, more, more,
maybe more blueberries, yeah. More?
No, none. I'm not putting in any.
Start again.
Go back to square one.
Call the whole thing off.
For his sweet soda bread, Peter is
taking the soda element literally.
The soda bread is gonna be
ginger beer flavour.
This is some green ginger wine
that I'm adding in
and then I'm also gonna add in just
some regular ginger beer as well,
and so should have really nice,
good flavour.
No, you've gotta layer it on there.
Yeah, a wee bit more.
Finance student Peter loves to bake
with his gluten-intolerant
brother Andrew
back home in Edinburgh.
That's fantastic finesse
and technique. I've spilled some.
And in honour of Andrew,
he's making his black pudding,
walnut and thyme loaf gluten-free.
What are you using
as the rising agents in there?
Just using bicarb as the rising
agent but I've got xanthe gum in it
to bind it. Yeah.
And keep it all together. OK.
For such a young head, you seem to
operate at quite a different level.
Have you always been into cooking
and baking?
Yeah, I've been into cooking
and baking for a very long time
but it genuinely has been
shows like Bake Off.
I mean, Bake Off's been around
for more than half of my life now,
so it's...
..yeah, pretty cool.
That accounts for all the grey hair.
All right, Old Father Time? Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Thank you, Peter.
The shape I'm going for
is to sort of replicate
what a chocolate bar would be like.
Basically a Whole Nut bar.
Like our Paul,
Dave is a bit of a petrolhead,
and he also follows Mr Hollywood's
lead when it comes to baking.
I was watching videos
of Paul Hollywood making it
just to see how you do it.
Dave's sweet loaf is inspired
by his favourite nut mix
and he's confident
that bacon and cheese
will prove to be
a savoury sensation.
I really enjoyed coming up with
the flavours
and making, like,
flavours that I like
but also a lot of people
would like as well.
That's ready...35 minutes.
With their second soda breads
in the oven,
it's time to concentrate on
the complementary butters.
Butter, would you believe, is the
easiest thing to make in the world.
At the moment
that's a thick double cream,
and it'll go past that stage
and then turn into butter.
And then when it curdles, you strain
all the milk fluids out of it
and that's it.
Never made butter.
I don't really know why you would.
I mean, it's lovely, it's very twee,
but why would you make butter?
I've just added some more
Irish stout into the butter
just to give it a bit of a kick.
This is from Mak, who left us,
sadly, on the last programme.
He didn't have a chance to
showcase his honey,
so that's going in for Mak.
Black garlic tastes a bit like
balsamic vinegar.
Don't ask me why I choose it.
I just thought I'd be a bit wild.
Let's see if that works.
Or it could well be my ticket home.
Paul's quite amazed at
your baking knowledge, isn't he,
cos you're so young. I hope that
I'm showing some good knowledge.
He fears you. He knows that
eventually the apprentice
always kills the master.
Be an interesting end
to Bake Off this year.
So what is it, ten minutes?
I tell them they've got ten minutes?
Yeah. OK. Ten minutes.
Bakers,
you have ten minutes.
You might need to do it
a bit louder.
Bakers,
you have ten minutes.
OK, let's see what we're
dealing with. It's hot. Ooh!
So it's spread a little bit more
than I'd have liked,
but no, it's traditional,
that shape so it's perfect.
So I'm tapping it just to hear
if it's hollow inside.
I think that's OK.
It's certainly cooked, anyway.
It could be darker in colour,
but I don't want it to overcook.
It's a bit of a take
on the Paddy's Pizza
that I learned to make at school.
Soda bread topped with tomato puree.
I want to do a little nod to that.
I think I'm gonna take that out.
I'm going with it.
It is what it is.
This one, it's very dense
with the marzipan,
so it kind of just looks raw.
It's not.
Is that not a sign, then,
that you shouldn't use marzipan?
No, I grated it. Oh, did you? Yeah.
I look forward to seeing
what happens.
Mate, it's gonna be carnage.
Carnage!
Oh, crumbs.
That wasn't good.
It just broke off.
We'll shove that to the back,
and they'll never know.
Don't know if you've got enough
blueberries in there. Look, Noel...
I just think if he says anything
about your cake that you don't like,
just grab a handful of blueberries
and mush them in his face.
Mush. Yeah, you should do it.
I won't.
Think my orange zest is a bit thick.
It's not really coming through
the piping nozzle.
It looks a bit messy.
Bakers, you have one minute left,
so if you haven't started
making your bread yet,
now is probably a good time.
It looks kind of like a poo.
Four-leaf clover.
I need plenty of luck.
Scary moment.
I think we're good. Hopefully
Nana Peg will be proud of that.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away from the breads.
Someone should tell Linda
that's not doing anything.
sponsors The Great British Bake Off.
The bakers' sweet and savoury soda
breads
now face the judgment of Paul and
Prue.
Hello, Mark. Hello. Hi, Mark. Hi.
I mean, they're quite impressive.
I do like the stout one.
It's the colour I expected it to be.
This has been coloured quite a bit,
but I don't really mind
that to be honest.
So we've got a sobrasada
and an Irish sheep smoked cheddar.
I think it's a decent soda bread.
There is flavour in there,
but you've got to hunt it.
I tell you what, it's delicious
if you taste it with the top,
then you really get the flavour.
Yeah, well, that's the cheese, yeah.
And then I've got chocolate
and Irish stout.
The chocolate comes through.
It's very good.
You do get the chocolate instantly
and then the stout lingers.
That's a great loaf.
And the butter's lovely. Thank you.
I think it's a good job. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Well done!
Ooh!
They look quite rustic,
but both the same size.
I think they look quite nice.
The onions and the chorizo
go really well together.
It's a little underbaked.
It's a pity because
the edge is perfect.
Right, glace cherry bread.
Ooh, look at that.
You can't taste the glace cherries,
but I'm getting the marzipan, which
is delicious. Oh, it's delicious.
The marzipan comes whacking
through. It's just lovely.
There's a good crunch to it. Hmm.
It's really lovely texture.
Beautiful.
I think it's a great-tasting loaf.
So do I.
You've chosen some flavours that
work in all breads,
and olive is one of those.
And my sweet is blueberry
and maple bacon.
Well, the blueberries are not
exactly evenly spread, are they?
But when I do get a blueberry,
it's delicious
and the texture's really good.
It's just that I'm missing the
bacon. It's wasted on the outside.
A lot of it's just going to end up
on the plate, as we see there,
and you're not going to taste it.
Thank you very much, Lottie.
Well done. Thank you.
Think the loaves look great.
It's very brave to take
the gluten-free option.
It's difficult, though, isn't it?
It's falling to bits a bit and then
it gets gluey in your mouth.
OK. This is the ginger?
Ginger beer, yeah.
I love that, I think
the texture's beautiful.
It's very cake-like, though,
isn't it?
I just think it's a little bit
stodgy.
I think the flavours are delicious.
Your flavours are normally spot on.
Very rustic, aren't they?
Yeah, they both look classic.
Yeah, really good.
I love that. Really?
Mm. It's a nice loaf.
If you get a mouthful of everything,
it's delicious. Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you very much. OK.
This one's a little doughier.
Bit more cake-like.
Nice flavour, though.
It's cranberries, is it?
Cranberries, chocolate and sea
salt.
I'm not getting the cranberry.
It's just a little bit weak.
Hmm. It just needs a bit more.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
They both look as if they
haven't risen quite enough.
There are very big lumps of sausage.
Oh, yes.
Do you always like a large sausage?
Don't care to comment.
OK, fair enough.
Actually, the sausage is OK,
the olives are OK.
The bread itself, I'd have
left it in longer. Right.
See how wet it is?
Oh, that's why it's heavy.
Yeah.
It would be nice if it was lighter.
Wow.
That much polenta in there, I think,
was a mistake.
It's too gritty for me.
It's a bit like eating a lemon
drizzle cake in a sandstorm.
It looks as if it's risen nicely.
Hasn't got enough flavour in it for
me. No?
Did you put gruyere in there? Yes.
You need double that. Treble that.
Yeah. OK.
You do get the chocolate,
you're just not getting enough in
each bite, that's my issue,
which is a shame cos it's baked
well, actually.
You made two very good loaves.
You just need a bit more flavour.
Let's try the za'atar one first.
What temperature did you put them
in the oven? 160.
That's why it's as pale as it is,
but the blend of the olives
with the za'atar is delicious.
Hmm, I like the flavour, too.
Right, sweet one.
So the fruit's mostly apricots?
Apricots, dried cherries and walnut.
I think that is delicious.
Thank you.
Really, really good.
My only issue with both those
is your temperature choice.
You should've baked it higher
and it would've been spot on for
both of them.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, thank you.
I think they look good, but I hope
that's baked all the way through
cos I get a bit worried
when they're that pale.
Just needed a little
longer in the oven.
It's such a pity
because the flavour is lovely.
That's a bit soggy, too.
Does have that spicy bara brith
flavour to it.
When you try and push a load of
fruit into a loaf,
if you shape it too tight, all
the fruit goes to the outside.
If you look inside, there's nothing
in there.
I like the flavour, but,
unfortunately, all the fruit burnt
on the top of the loaf, not in it.
Yeah.
I think, overall, they look really
nice.
I think the idea of putting a smoked
salmon in it is so original.
I've never had that.
You invented a bread!
That, I really like.
The salmon in there really works.
It's like a whole sandwich all in
one.
The aftertaste is lovely as well.
It's nice, that, and it's well
baked. Thank you.
Well, that's a very grown-up fruit
cake. Lots of booze. Lovely!
I've soaked the fruit
a couple of weeks.
A couple of weeks? Are you serious?
Wow. She wanted us to taste it.
It's lovely. Thank you.
Hermine, I think they're very
special. I really do.
Thank you.
Do you know what I love? I love the
fact that I've never had 'em before
and this is what Bake Off's all
about.
This is really, really complex in
its flavours.
I love it, I think it's special.
Well done.
That's it - I'm packing.
Time to go home.
That's 2020 over!
That went better than I expected.
I was terrified, I'll be honest with
you, but the flavour queen is back.
The comments were not
entirely positive,
but I'm very determined,
learning from the last technical,
to spend a bit of time thinking and
not just dashing straight into it.
Bread week isn't about to
get any easier.
Our ten bakers will now face
a technical...with a twist.
Bakers, it's time for your technical
challenge,
which, today, has been set by Paul.
Paul, any words of advice?
You need to get your timings right.
Yeah, he said words of advice,
not just words.
As ever, your technical
challenge will be judged blind
so we're going to have to ask these
two rascals to skedaddle.
Off you pop.
# Go on now, go
# Walk out the door
# Just turn around now
# You're not welcome any more. #
So, Paul would like you to bake
six rainbow-coloured bagels.
Rainbow coloured bagels are the same
as normal bagels,
just with five different-coloured
doughs.
Layered, shaped then boiled
and baked
to achieve a lovely, shiny, chewy
crust.
Chewy crust.
You have two hours and 45 minutes.
On your marks.
Get set.
Bake.
Oh, my God.
What the hell is a rainbow bagel?
I mean...
No idea.
Never made them before, certainly
not a rainbow one, so...interesting.
I have made bagels before,
but I don't want to say, like,
"Oh, I've made bagels before and
then they come out awful."
Kind of makes sense when you
read it through. Just go with it.
There's a bagel shop near work
so I've seen how they make it,
but I've never made it myself.
I wouldn't have to - it's right
there.
Paul.
Paul, why rainbow-coloured bagels?
Well, I think bagels are a great
challenge when you're making bread.
You've got to boil them, which is
unusual, and then bake them as well.
I think the rainbow colours
for me, although it originated
over in the States, I think it
represents the NHS.
Well, it does now.
It does now, certainly.
Now, basically, what they've got to
do is roll each piece, each colour,
into a rectangle and then you lay
the next one on the top
all the way up. You stack them.
Yes, and twist it to create that
spiral and then you seal.
You plunge it in the water for
anything between 15 and 40 seconds
and then pop in the oven,
bake it off.
Can we taste them? Absolutely.
What could go wrong?
You can overprove and underprove
very easily on a bagel.
If they've overproved it before
it's gone in the water or
if they leave it in the water too
long, it will flatten in the oven.
It's absolutely delicious.
It's even brighter
inside than it is outside.
Pretty vibrant, Prue.
They may have made bagels before,
but I guarantee they wouldn't have
made 'em like this.
I've never made them like this.
Happy bread. Happy bread,
that's what it is.
Make and knead the dough.
It's, erm...scant, isn't it, at
best?
So I normally would just chuck
it in a stand mixer.
We're definitely getting a full
workout today.
We're in 2020. Who kneads by hand?
I know it needs to be kneaded
a good amount for a bagel
so I'm going to be working this
until it's super, super smooth.
Think it's got to be quite
a stretchy, elastic dough.
It still feels a little tight.
Stretch and tear, that's how to go.
Rowan's doing the slap already.
Whack it.
It's very therapeutic, it really is.
So disappointed that there aren't
any rainbows in a rainbow bagel.
Real rainbows?
I wanted you to have to go
and catch a rainbow.
Yeah. Lasso it, chop it up,
grate it into the bagel.
But, no, it's just some coloured
bread.
I think that must be about it now.
And then it says to divide
the dough into five pieces.
We colour them each a
different colour.
I've never done coloured bread
before
so it's all part of the voyage
of discovery, really.
It's a very messy business.
# Red and yellow and
pink and green... #
Don't know the words to the
rainbow song.
I suspect they want to be nice
and vibrant.
It's really hard to
mix in all the colours.
I might have used too much, just
judging by the fact that
no-one else's bench is the same
colour as mine.
You're a Smurf, aren't you? Yes.
Right, that'll do. I'm over that.
Number four, rise.
Exceptionally descriptive.
Arise, sir dough.
I'm going to leave it to prove
until it's doubled in size.
It's only small pieces.
I'm going to go about 20 minutes
to start with.
And breathe.
I would normally snooze
or play the piano, actually,
while the dough was rising or
perhaps do a spot of gardening.
I could nip outside and do
a little bit of pruning.
If you prod and it leaves a slight
indent, then they're ready to go,
so they're doing all of that so
I think it's time to go with them.
Going to start rolling them
out in colour order, so red first.
Is this from the handshake?
Is this what happens with Paul?
That's his fake tan.
You know they can take handshakes
back? Oh, yeah.
They'll just reverse the footage.
It'll be like...
Roll out to a rectangle,
measuring 15 by 12 centimetres.
I'm just going to check what
15 centimetres looks like,
just so I know.
What are you comparing it against?
Just half the ruler, Dave.
So you're actually just layering
the doughs.
I'm just trying to get
some kind of evenness.
It's like making very brightly
coloured mattresses.
They're very bouncy and very
illuminous.
So now I'm cutting
the dough into six.
You have to do, roll and twist
the dough to a rope
measuring approximately
24 centimetres long.
You are approximately 24.
I am, aren't I? We've got
the 24 centimetres. Yeah.
How many inches is that?
I think in inches.
Erm, that's nine and a half inches.
I think that's respectable myself.
Kind of pull back on this palm
and go forward on this palm.
Oh, dear.
This is a rainbow, isn't it?
There you go.
Just got to try
and seal this bit now.
Gently roll backwards and forwards.
Don't get it.
I don't want it to fall apart.
Haven't got a clue!
It's not too bad. Once you get
the knack of it, it's like, woo!
Oh, look - everyone's twisted
theirs. I didn't twist mine.
I think it's about right cos they're
going to expand so that hole's going
to shrink and I think by the time
it's expanded and shrunk,
it should be about right.
It does say twist, it does say
twist. Does it? Yeah.
It says "roll and twist".
Bakers, you are halfway through.
And number ten is "prove".
Just the one word in that step.
He's not very elaborate, is he?
So I want to give them as much
time as possible, really.
I think the trick with these is the
timing.
The second prove is really going to
be the one for texture.
Try that again, shall we?
I'll put the drawer up a bit warmer,
see if we can get a quicker prove on
the go.
And we'll see how we get on.
Judging the right time to stop
the final prove is critical.
It's even driven me to drink green
tea.
Come on. That's gin, we know. Yeah.
If I was on this competition,
I'd drink though it.
I've started drinking.
I've not drank for four years.
Here, I've started
drinking in the evening.
If the bagels are underproved...
Anything happening in there?
..they won't have the dome-like rise
that Paul and Prue are expecting.
Oh, check you out!
They're looking good!
It doesn't look bad, actually.
Reckon they're about ready.
Right, glasses off.
"And bring a saucepan of water to a
boil. Add the bicarbonate of soda."
If they're overproved,
they'll puff up too much when they
hit the water...
Who's going to take the plunge
first?
..and collapse before
they go into the oven.
So let's have a look.
It's where I feel a bit nervous
cos I don't think they cook long.
"Cook until the bagels are puffed
and the shape has set."
I think this is what gives the
bagels that chewy kind of texture.
So I'm boiling them for about
30 to 45 seconds on each side.
I have no idea whether that's done.
You seen the size of them?
They're huge.
Bakers, you have 30 minutes left.
Have I missed it? Yes.
Not doing any more than that.
They go in looking good
and then things happen.
This is not a bagel.
This is a unicorn horn.
It's hard to know, isn't it?
I know, especially when you've never
made them before.
Why don't you, like, look up
and see what other people are doing?
I have been, but theirs aren't
looking terribly good either.
Is that set? So hard to know.
Let's have 'em in a bit longer.
Ooh!
Paul Hollywood is definitely taking
his handshake back cos these...
Hmm.
Yeah, so that's them all boiled now.
Even though they've doubled in size,
they seem to have lost it when I've
boiled them.
I got it.
This one opened up,
but don't tell Paul.
But I've stuck it back together
and hopefully it'll just glue back
together in the oven.
Going into the oven now.
It just says bake.
We'll see what the oven does with
'em.
Could be just a case of getting
a nice crust on them.
20 maximum, I think.
I don't know for how long.
I'm hoping they'll puff up again
and it will disguise the wrinkly
bits they've now got.
Ba-bakers, you've got, ooh...
ten minutes left!
That's not very much time, is it?
So how do you know they're ready?
Cos normally they'll get brown.
These got colour.
My blue's way too dark.
I really don't know what
I'm looking for.
I'm not loving what's going
on inside there.
I think they're a bit too thin and
too wide.
I think they're going to want them
to be a bit...puffier.
They in there? They're in there.
They're looking pretty good.
Yours not so much.
Oh, look, Sura looks sad.
You all right? Yeah.
Do you want a piggy back?
No. OK.
Do not want to overbake them.
Another minute.
What have we got?
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
Ohhh!
I'm just looking to make sure
they're not going too brown.
They look great, Linda.
Mine are all kind of wrinkled.
And they have been
boiled for some time.
I think I'm going to take 'em out.
That looks good. Well done.
They sound hollow, so...
Yeah, they sound done.
Flat as pancakes.
Bakers, your time is up.
That's not a bagel.
I'll be honest...I think
I've overcooked all of them.
Just strategic placing.
Exactly!
Mine seem kind of soft and
wrinkly...
..which is not attractive!
Paul and Prue are looking for six
vibrant, rainbow-coloured bagels
that are smooth and crisp on the
outside and slightly chewy inside.
We've got the five vivid colours.
Right...
These aren't too bad.
You've got the colours.
And they're quite smooth.
And quite light.
They're a lot smaller
than most of the others.
They're a good size.
Nice and soft,
crispy on the outside.
Very nice. It's nice bread.
All the same size, nice and smooth
and the crumb's really tasty
as well.
Good. Very good.
Right, moving on to the Hula Hoops.
These are a little bit big
and, actually, it's overproved.
It's flat.
Tastes all right, though.
Mm, tastes fine.
Moving on to these whoppers.
They haven't been twisted.
You can see where it's joined,
but it's just gone round as one.
Colours are nice -
very bright and vibrant.
Nice flavour, though.
It's a nice flavour. Good texture.
Right, moving on to this.
Very, very flat.
Again, they've been overproved
before they went in the water
and then afterwards,
they'd lost all their height.
Taste great, though.
Now, these are a little bit dark.
Just feel the crispiness here.
Yeah.
But, actually,
the shape, pretty uniform.
It's actually... They're not too
bad. Just slightly overbaked.
Now these, again, have had the issue
with the water, overproved.
You can see the marks on it.
That's not at all crisp
and it's soft.
Underbaked. The flavour's OK,
though. Flavour's fine.
Now, these aren't bad,
these are fairly smooth,
but they've just overdone it
slightly in the water.
Good flavour.
These are overbaked again.
You see how dark they've gone?
They're not very attractive.
Bit tough.
These are big.
They look more like pretzels,
but they're vibrant colours,
and they are pretty smooth.
Mm.
Yeah. That is delicious.
It is nice.
Now, moving on to the last one.
Lost its way a little bit
in the shaping,
but also with the water as well.
Again, see, the marks?
Nice bread, though.
OK, this is going to be interesting
to judge.
Paul and Prue
will now rank the bagels...
That one second from the end's good.
..from worst to best.
So, in last place...
..we have this one.
Rowan, they are overproved
and underbaked.
In ninth spot we have this one.
You've actually managed to bake this
one, but it is overproved.
And then, in eighth place,
we have this one.
Sura, lovely colour.
Your twisting wasn't perfect.
It was a little bit wobbly.
Hermine is seventh,
Laura is sixth,
Lottie, fifth,
and Peter, fourth.
In third, we have this one.
Not bad at all.
You've managed to get a nice colour.
It's got the nice twist in there.
And in second place...
..we have this one.
Who's that? Marc,
they are really nice bagels.
They're properly risen, good effort.
And in first place,
we have this one.
Well done, Linda.
It's nice and chewy.
You've got lovely colours inside
with the flavour as well.
Thank you.
They tasted really good.
Well done, Linda.
Oh, wow! What a high.
Can't wait to tell my family.
I can't wait to tell Richard.
I'll ring him up
and I'll just go, "Argh!"
That was a good result for me.
The last two Technicals,
I've not fared too well,
so, yeah, I was really happy
with that one.
Well, I had a fabulous time.
It was a really good challenge.
The result wasn't great.
Tomorrow, we can do better.
Got to do better.
Just one challenge remains.
So, Bread Week, something
very close to your heart, Paul.
I think, overall, the standards have
been pretty good.
It was nice to give out
a handshake to Hermine.
I think she did really well. Yeah.
Very clever.
She invented a new genre of bread.
But, for Star Baker, I think
she struggled a little bit
in the Technical.
I'm not saying she's not.
There are a couple of other people.
Both Marks have done well
in Signature and Technical. Yeah.
And, actually, Lottie as well.
Lottie described
herself as a swan.
She said, "Oh, you don't know what's
going on beneath the surface."
She is not swan like.
She's always just going, "Urgh...!"
I've never seen a swan
panicking that hard.
"Urgh...!"
Who's in trouble?
I think Rowan, he's in difficulty
this week again.
Those soda breads,
one was a polenta cake.
One was a sandpit.
It was very sandy.
I think David's actually done OK,
but he is slipping down there.
Curse of the Star Baker!
Ultimately, it's quite a tricky
Showstopper today,
but what I'd like to see is all
the bakers complete the task -
including Rowan.
Interesting. Interesting.
I think I'm in love with you.
Shall we talk about this later?
I think we should talk about it now.
Hello, bakers,
welcome back to the tent.
It's time for
your Showstopper Challenge.
Today, the judges would like you to
make a large decorative bread plaque
in the style of a traditional
harvest festival sheaf.
Giving your own take on the sheaf,
your bread plaque must portray
the one thing
you are most grateful for.
Your bread must be impressive
in size, visually powerful
and, of course, it's got to be
delish-delosh.
You have three hours and 30 minutes.
Don't seem long enough!
I know, they've been
done up like a kipper!
On your marks...
..get set...
..bake!
Feeling nervous today.
It's a big one.
Traditionally the harvest plaque
is completely inedible
and rock hard and varnished,
so to have to make it utterly
delicious,
it's quite a challenge, really.
Bricking it.
Now, the bread plaque itself must be
a celebration of something that
the bakers are thankful for.
It could be your house, it could be
their health - it could be anything.
But it's really easy to sit there
and design something
elaborate on paper.
It's not anything like easy
to make it in bread.
It's about manipulating dough
itself, using knife techniques,
plaiting, twisting, spiralling
the bread.
I think it's a great challenge
because it'll give me the indication
of how far these bakers have
travelled on their bread journey.
And I hope they've practised it
because they'll never get it right
if they haven't.
To give their elaborate
plaques different flavours, textures
and shapes, all of the bakers have
chosen to make multiple breads.
I'm making three breads,
there's a lot of multitasking
going on.
There's no time for faffery today.
So, I'm doing two breads - a basic
white bread, a wholemeal bread
and then, around the edges, I've got
this Tibetan monastery bread.
Flavoured with fennel,
coriander and caraway seeds,
Marc's bread will be swirled
together
to form a Buddhist dharma wheel.
Are you a Buddhist?
Is this what you're grateful for?
I'm not a Buddhist, no, but after I
had the accident where I lost my leg
and I wasn't in a very good place...
..and just trying to come to terms
with what had happened,
I picked up a wonderful book.
It was about the philosophy
of Buddhism.
It made it a lot clearer what
I needed to do to kind of still
live a life and make my life
worth living, you know?
So this, yeah, it means
a lot to me, this one.
I'm going to knead it
for about ten minutes.
It's not too sticky.
More smooth and silky.
Nowhere near ready.
Give it some real welly.
Good bit of exercise, which
I'm slightly missing at the moment.
I just absolutely love
this part about bread.
You can put so much feeling into it.
Can put a lot of love into it,
you know?
Linda's putting her love
into two family favourite.
A black olive plait will frame
tiger bread animals that she helped
look after on her uncle's farm.
As a kid, I used to milk the cows
and we used to carry the buckets
of milk up through the farm
to my auntie's kitchen,
where she made beautiful cakes.
So rural idyll, isn't it?
Beautiful. Oh, yeah.
You've really gone for the harvest
theme, then, haven't you?
Absolutely, yeah.
It's all about that circle of life.
All right, thank you, Linda.
Thank you. Thank you. Good luck.
Shape of that bottle even reminds me
of the milk churns.
It's a wonderful memory. Mm!
I'll have a little pipe
in a minute.
La-la, la-la, la-la, la...
Linda's not the only baker
celebrating the good life.
I'm feeling very grateful
for my life in Worcestershire
and the wonderful countryside
and the theatre, literature
and music that form such
a big part of my life there.
Rowan's huge plaque will be
made of three flavoured breads
and shaped into Worcestershire's
coat of arms - the pear tree.
He's hoping it'll be enough
to make up for yesterday's
Technical disaster.
Did you come...? Last!
Did you? Of course, yeah.
But if you smash this, then...
But it's probably curtains,
but I'm going to have fun anyway.
I love your attitude.
And also - look at your boots.
This is strong boot game right here.
Look at that, look at that.
Look at these two guys.
While Rowan's taking on
the biggest bread plaque...
It seems to be enormous
compared with everybody else's.
..Hermine might have the most
ambitious plan of them all.
The plan is to make
an enriched dough.
Something to close a brioche.
It can't be a brioche
in three and a half hours.
What have you cut back on
to get it done in the time?
I haven't cut back on anything.
It's supposed to stay
in the fridge overnight,
but I'm going to put it
in the freezer on both sides
for about 15 minutes to harden
the butter so that I can then work.
Quite risky.
I agree.
Hermine's brioche will form
the border of her focaccia
and breadstick plaque
recreating her annual road trips
from London to Paris
to visit family and friends.
They might say it's risky,
doing an enriched dough,
but I like doing it,
so I'm going to do it anyway.
We shall see.
While Hermine is
heading to the freezer...
Think that's probably done now.
Yeah, can you see,
the light's coming through?
So that's good to go.
Proving drawer - there it is.
..the other bakers
are ready to start proving.
Grow. So that's in for an hour.
Quite warm in here today,
so hopefully it'll just rise
without having to force it up.
I'm going to go by eye today.
Set the timer for 40 minutes
and just see how it looks.
With one dough down...
Right back to some kneading.
..the process starts all over again.
I've added fresh yeast.
The first load will go 15.
We'll give this one 20, just to let
it kind of catch up a little bit.
So, in theory, this should all be
proved around the same time.
And if juggling multiple doughs
wasn't tricky enough...
This is the most manic bit.
..some of the bakers have chosen
to make fillings as well.
The mango, lime and chilli taste is,
like,
my signature flavour for bread.
It's just fantastic.
That smells delish.
I've got a focaccia base which is
stuffed with pancetta,
Padano and Gruyere cheese.
It's basically a posh cheese
and ham sandwich.
Laura's stuffed focaccia
will take centre stage
of her musical-themed plaque
which will be adorned with
spicy fougasse curtains and masks.
I've probably seen about 70 shows
in the West End.
And I've seen none. Really?
You've never been to
a West End musical? No, never.
Call yourself a gay man?!
Honestly, terrible.
When this show is over,
we are hitting the town! OK.
We're going to take him to Wicked...
Yeah.
..Mamma Mia, Phantom, Les Mis...
We'll make a list. OK.
We'll make a list.
Sounds good. It's a date.
So, I'm just pureeing my apples.
I grew up in County Armagh
in Northern Ireland,
which is known as Orchard County
because of all the apple orchards.
I'm going to freeze the apple puree
in straws
and then I will braid around
the frozen puree.
I hope it works. Fingers crossed.
Mark's also taking a chance with
his flavours,
combining his apple-filled trees
with hazelnut and wild garlic.
Will Prue and Paul love apple
and wild garlic? I'm not sure.
But I love it. I think it's such
an amazing taste
So I'm going to put that in
for its first prove now.
As more dough begins proving...
Ready to go.
..Hermine's brioche dough
is finally cold enough to shape.
I'm twisting. I'm a bit pushed
for time.
Cos I don't want the butter melting.
But I think it will be fine
to go prove now.
Just on time.
Might be ready in time to bake.
I hope so.
Ah!
90 minutes remain for the bakers to
complete their decorative
bread plaques...
This is such enormous fun.
It's just a shame it's a
competition, really.
..and their first batch of dough has
risen to the occasion.
The focaccia has doubled in size.
Good rise.
And any additional ingredients...
..can now be added.
I need that.
Hazelnuts going in, I want to
really make sure I get it in
and just not on the top. It smells
amazing, doesn't it?
Oh!
I'm just putting in very mature
Somerset Cheddar
and a Spanish chorizo.
This is going to be an incorporated
dough.
It's a tricky one to get right.
I've warmed the pre-soaked pear.
I didn't want it to cool the dough
and impede the rise.
It doesn't want to go as flat as a
pancake and stodgy,
which is another of my trademarks.
This is the canvas for the
bread plaque.
I'm just going to start
shaping it.
Oh, that's stuck. Well done, Sura!
Once her canvas is ready,
Sura's recreating one of her
most cherished childhood memories,
picking tomatoes off the vine her
mum grew in their London flat.
It was huge.
It was behind the TV in the living
room...like that.
It was on the ceiling and so
whenever I see a tomato vine,
I remember my mum.
She's like my favourite
person on the Earth.
Very thankful for her.
Dave is also giving thanks
to his family...
So, I'm making a bread plaque
of my house,
with the family stood outside
the front.
..which is soon getting a new
addition.
Very excited about being a dad,
yeah, really looking forward to it.
We're expecting a boy. Stacey says
I'm very laidback with kids.
It will be baking, DIY, driving.
Dave's giving his Hampshire home
far flung flavours
inspired by a holiday to Mexico.
Woven hibiscus and guava bread will
sit under a mango, chilli roof.
Are you doing like a shed?
No shed that's in the back garden.
Garden shed? So from....
What about a driveway?
No driveway, no.
Garage? Recycling bins?
No.
Anything else, Matt?
Decking outside?
No decking, no.
I just think cos it's 2020,
maybe some solar panels.
But we don't have solar panels
on our house at the moment, so...
You don't? No. I might get a solar
panel on my head,
just to give me more energy.
Over the long run, it'd be
cheaper than coffee.
Dave's not the only baker...
What part of my house is that?
..grateful for their humble abode.
I live with aunt and my uncle
and my two cousins.
It's by the beach,
it's a lovely place to be,
so I am making my house.
Lottie's sun-dried tomato and
chorizo beach house
will be surrounded by pesto palm
trees and bushes.
I am doing this in a proving bag,
so that I can work on it
whilst it's proving.
But while Lottie and Dave are
finding it hard enough
to build one house...
It's not easy when you're
restricted.
This makes it look like I'm
performing some bizarre operation.
..Peter's taking on an entire city.
I'm making an Edinburgh cityscape
bread plaque.
I made these and did the drawing
myself.
But he's got one more step before
construction can begin.
I've chosen to make a bagel dough
because after you've boiled it,
then it sets its shape and you're
actually able to get
pretty precise cuts out of it.
A seeded multigrain dough will form
the rocky backdrop
to his poppy seed covered
Edinburgh landmarks.
We did have a little practice on
bagels yesterday.
I think I'm going to slightly change
how I do it,
in response to their comments.
I want to try and make it
slightly lighter.
Bakers, you have
one hour left.
Ah, Matthew!
God this time's disappearing
already, isn't it?
Just have to crack on.
This is the trunk of the tree.
Bit concerned about Rowan.
He seems confident that he'll get
this finished in the time
but he is taking on a lot - again.
Crack on with the decoration.
I agree with you, there's such
a lot going on.
I just hope to goodness he finishes.
There is a plan -
I know that's surprising -
and, so far, I think I'm going to
it.
I'm not happy with the rise.
It needs a bit more time.
Hermine is doing brioche.
Brioche in three and a half hours is
tricky to do. Yeah.
So it's going to be interesting
to see, certainly with her
French background, what she can come
up with.
I'm going to carry on proving this.
While Hermine's wait goes on...
That's looking good.
..the rest of the bakers' dough has
finished proving...
I'm happy with my tiger bread,
that's come up lovely.
Oh!
..and their intricate designs can
now begin to take shape.
So, here we go.
The judges are expecting a variety
of bread shaping techniques.
I've tried to show twists
and some plaits,
but just hoping that my flavours
will make up for the fact
that I'm not the most intricate of
bakers.
This is just my frozen apple
puree.
I'll push them out of the straws
and braid it over the top.
Just want to sure I've got that
good definition in there.
But the bakers need to work quickly.
Your bread's going to continue to
prove, so you're not going to get
anything defined enough if you
don't get your move on.
I'm not very good at plaiting...
..so it is a little bit tricky.
It's not as good looking as the
other one.
I'm really happy with the way that
that's come round, yeah.
Hopefully, when it bakes, it won't
get too many pfft...
..like a hernia.
This is the canopy of the tree.
It looks just like a bit of a
shambles at the moment
but a few well-placed details can
bring a whole thing to life.
The pears go on next.
Does that look like a tractor?
Not quite, does it?!
These are the tomatoes with
feta inside.
This is the Forth rail bridge.
I'm going to give it a red eggwash
before it goes in the oven.
It comes out rusty red colour
that looks fairly similar
to the real thing.
The ties are going to be sprayed
gold.
I think Paul's going to hate it
but he doesn't like glitter,
he doesn't like the theatre, I mean,
pretty sad life if you ask me.
Have you see Matt in Les Mis?
I did. He was amazing!
I genuinely mean it when I say it
was the best thing
I've ever seen in the West End.
Really?!
I've seen it about five times.
Wow.
It's quite a mess over here.
Look at it.
I know! I think I'm the messy one
out of the group, to be fair.
Wow, look at it. I'm all right with
that. I've got loads to do.
Yeah, I know sorry. Bye-bye.
Love you!
I have a wheel. This is starting to
come together now.
This is my twist to go on the
outside.
How far can I make that stretch?
Oh, well that's sad.
What about if I just do that?
No-one would ever know.
This is a tiger glaze and I've tamed
it down so that it doesn't
crack up too much.
I'm painting it with spirulina and
then I've got some beetroot powder
on the tomatoes.
Stacey's pregnant and a furlough
belly for me.
Hopefully, the dough will rise in
the right places.
I am going in... For possibly
the last time.
Please be good to me, little bread.
Don't drop it, don't drop it,
don't drop it.
I'm going to put it in for... 35.
Yeah, in she goes!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
I'm going to have about four minutes
to spare, I think.
I'm having to rush these.
I'm really out of time now and I
need to get this in the oven.
Bakers, you
have half an hour left.
Right, it's going in.
That's 30 minutes.
Oh, crumbs, right, I'm going in.
Let's get on with some baking!
That was really close.
It needs 30 minutes.
I've got exactly 30 minutes.
My brioche, it hasn't proved
as well as I wanted.
I'm going to give it
a bit more time.
Oh, it feels like that's the
challenge over though.
It's really weird.
Have a little clean up now.
I take every opportunity that I can
just to try and take
a mindful breath.
Just like bring me back to the
present moment,
cos when you think about it,
when we're worrying,
we're worrying about things that
have happened in our past...
Don't think I should've floured it,
to be honest.
..or we're worrying
about the future.
Have you got enough time to cook it?
I hope so.
And, ultimately, we've got no
control over that, have we?
But, of course, it's easier
said than done.
Bakers, you've got 15 minutes.
Paul Hollywood wants bread
and if he doesn't get it,
he's going to be furious.
You ain't baking,
you're going to be quaking!
That should take about 15 minutes,
hopefully.
It's going to be really close.
I'm just worried about the base,
so I think I might up it, you know.
That's coming out now.
# Ah, ah, ah-ah! #
Not bad!
Hopefully, it's baked.
That does sound hollow.
That sounds brilliant.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
Let's trim those bits off.
There're an awful lot of leaves to
paint green,
so I need to get busy with that.
I'll give it a make-up job.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
I think it's cooked.
Is it just us three in the ovens?
Just us three, yeah.
Hmm, that's too big.
Just take it carefully and slowly.
So, there's a lot to trim.
Going in!
Urgh! Everyone's is out.
This is my chilli oil.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away from your bread.
I've done it.
Amazing.
Well done, Hermine.
Oh!
It'll probably taste appalling but
I'm quite pleased with the look.
We'll go with it.
Just hope I've done enough.
It's judgement time for our bakers'
decorative bread plaques.
Hermine, would you like to bring
up your Showstopper, please?
Looks a bit abstract.
You're driving through vineyards,
are you? Yes.
So there's grapes. These?
Um, that's supposed to be a farmer's
field and there's a tractor.
Oh, that's a tractor. Yes.
Oh, it's there, OK.
You've lost a bit of definition
in the swirl on the outside,
but, overall, it looks good.
OK, well, let's have a look
at the frame to start with.
This is the brioche.
Yes.
And then the main bit is
the focaccia.
Yeah.
The brioche doesn't hold
much flavour.
I knew you were going to struggle to
get that out in time.
It's an enriched dough,
but it's certainly not a brioche.
Focaccia's lovely. Thank you.
It's springy, I like both, actually.
The focaccia's not bad.
But I do like the design.
It's very, very good. Thank you.
I think it looks quite
dramatic and effective.
The plait on the outside's not bad.
I like the effect you've got
by interlacing the two.
Texture looks good.
I think that is
beautifully seasoned.
The tomato bread is nice as well -
it's got a nice zing to it.
But, more importantly,
it's the structure,
the air bubbles,
it's regular
and it's even all the way down.
It's a nice loaf. Thank you.
Did you try one of the balls?
They've got feta inside.
Mm.
That is delicious.
Can I go? Yes, absolutely.
Thank you.
Your agony is over.
Well done, Sura. Well done.
Thank you.
I love your Victorian swags
of great velvet curtains,
your gilded tassels are wonderful.
It's simple but effective.
Shall we have a look at it, then?
Yeah.
It's a focaccia base with pancetta
and cheese.
It's got quite a punch, hasn't it?
Your ingredient choices are good.
The problem is focaccia's a very,
very light dough
and you put that on the top of it,
so it couldn't rise,
so what it did is
concertina back down again
and so it feels quite raw.
It is a pity,
because, when you get a bit of
the edge of the focaccia,
it's really nice bread.
The chilli bread's got a kick to it.
Yeah, it's not bad at all.
I think it's full of flavour,
but the textures weren't right.
It's simple.
It's sort of effective.
I think you could've done more
with it, though.
All your flavours are coming
from the seeds on the top,
the dried herbs.
They sort of carry through.
It's a nice eat, isn't it?
It tastes very nice. I just feel
it's a little dense and tough.
You made a bagel like a pitta.
It's a little weird.
It is, isn't it?
You shouldn't be able to do
that with bread.
It's like a piece of leather.
Oh, Peter...
I think the design's
pretty good.
You've kept some definition in there
as well, which is nice.
That bread's beautifully risen.
It feels great, but it lacks
flavour. OK.
And this is tomato and paprika?
That's, yeah, tomato,
paprika and chorizo.
That packs a punch. That's nice.
Very nice.
Nice balance of flavour
with it as well.
That's a nice bread - you should've
done more with that... Very nice.
..rather than the white.
I like the concept,
I like the design, I love the cow.
We drank milk straight from the cow
when we was children.
From the udders? Not quite, Noel.
Wow.
Remind me of the flavour again?
It's olive and tiger bread.
But that's not the tiger
bread topping.
It's the flavours of it
but not so much the cracking.
OK.
It's quite dense.
More olives are needed,
more proving's needed,
more flavour's needed.
Interesting trees.
Little bit bulky, compared with
the rest of it.
I like the little bee.
The plaiting's a little bit
irregular, thick and then thin.
The structure's not bad,
because, actually,
you do have a light crust
and it is wetter on the mouth
which is what you want.
Flavour's not that strong, though,
considering you're using
wild garlic,
you should be getting a serious kick
from that. Hm. Hm.
This one's got apple
and cinnamon in it.
Apple and cinnamon in the middle,
yeah, yeah.
Hm, the apple
and cinnamon's really nice.
It's a bit basic, the picture,
but the bread is OK.
Well, it looks really surprising
and pretty and quite neat.
Certainly colourful.
If you dig a little deeper
around the edges,
it's a little bit weak on the
plaiting. Yes.
It's slightly underproved
so it's ripped in the oven. OK.
But this particular area here
is gorgeous. Thank you.
Really nice, neat, clever.
- It's intricate detail, isn't it?
- Lovely colours.
Ah, look.
And that looks nice bread.
The flavour of the brown's not bad.
It could do with a little bit
more salt. OK.
Fennel one, particularly, is nice.
But, overall, I like those flavours.
Thank you very much.
Marc, I think
you've done a really good job.
It looks good, tastes good,
smells good, it is good.
That's great. Thank you very much.
Thank you. Thank you.
Well done.
OK, thanks, thank you very much.
Your wife's pregnant?
Yes, yeah, although I do look more
pregnant than she does.
I was going to say.
It's called sympathetic pregnancy.
I would've spent time
cutting bricks out
and placed them on,
and just built up
that brickwork look.
I mean, you sort of get it, but it
would look nice with that. OK.
This is the one with mango.
Mango, lime and chilli paste
running through.
Well, you certainly get the mango
and the chilli.
I like the flavour. I've never had
anything quite like that.
But I just think the bread's
a little bit too dry,
it's overbaked. OK.
And the flavour of the base?
That is hibiscus
and guava flavour drops.
I've never met guava flavour.
Never had an Um Bongo, Prue?
You've never been to the
Congo.
Oh, no, I know guavas well, but I've
never known it as an essence.
Right. And I can't really taste it.
But the ideas are unique.
I've never tried either of them
before.
It's just that the baking was
a little bit too far.
Yeah, all right, fair enough.
Thank you.
You need a hand, right?
I do, please.
Let's do this.
Is that going to fit?
Let's hope.
Well, Rowan...
Overall, I think it looks great.
I think it looks quite attractive.
Very big. What's the bread there?
Worcestershire blue cheese
and pears soaked in local cider.
Get the cider.
And where's the blue cheese?
Well, I pressed it in.
You pressed it in, OK, that's why
we're not getting the taste. Right.
And, actually, I would've mixed
it in the dough
and you needed much more
proving in that.
Keeping these restrained to keep
the look,
you've gone for all style
and no substance.
You've ended up with a bread
which is actually quite bland.
Right. What's the flavour of that
one?
That is chestnut and walnut.
Again, walnuts, a lot more.
It's such a pity cos
that's a much nicer bread.
Shall we try the earthy one?
I can smell the truffle.
It definitely has more flavour,
but it could do with some salt.
OK. Thank you very much.
Many thanks.
All style, no substance - that's me.
I'd rather be all style,
no substance, anyway.
Somewhat disappointed, I was very
happy with the look of it,
and, so, I'm glad to have done
what I could do.
Feeling a little uneasy.
I might be home tomorrow,
but I haven't phoned her yet.
Oh, it'd mean a lot to be
able to come back next week.
That went better than expected.
Usually, I hear these things
from my parents
and I just thought,
"It's cos you're my parents."
But it's nice to hear it from them.
Really happy with that,
really happy.
Oh, it'd feel amazing, I think,
if they called out that
I was star baker for the week.
Uh, but, yeah,
I don't know how I'd handle it.
So how do you think that went?
I think overall,
the standard wasn't particularly
good. I think they feel
a lot of pressure on Bread Week
to impress you,
and often, they implode.
They needed to come in strong,
didn't they?
If you're not confident,
it'll always show.
Sura and Marc E, those two
had terrific confidence
and they're bang in your face.
They both managed to get the right
texture,
the right flavour, the right look.
So star baker, Marc E and Sura.
Yeah.
What about Hermine? She had a
handshake yesterday.
Hermine has a possibility.
Didn't do brilliant
in the technical.
And her showstopper,
I didn't like the enriched dough.
Who do you think is down the
bottom?
Obviously, Rowan is. Anyone else?
I think Peter's in trouble I also
think David's in trouble as well.
Our two previous star bakers. Yeah.
In defence of Rowan,
his showstopper really looked like a
showstopper, didn't it? It did.
Again, style and substance.
It lacked flavour.
But how much flavour
do breads really need?
You've crossed the line.
I've crossed the line.
Do you want a fight, Matt?
So bakers, congratulations. I know
it's been a long couple of days.
One of you is star baker,
and that person is...
Marc E.
Oh, bakers, that means I've got
the horrible job
of sending someone home.
The person who is leaving us is...
Rowan.
Oh! That's fine.
These boots were made for walking.
I feel very content, really.
I've had a wonderful time.
Um, it is exhausting,
but very rewarding.
Bring it in, bring it in, kids.
Sorry, Rowan.
And I was also quite pleased
that Noel said to me,
"Well, I'm all style
and no substance".
He said, "It's on my CV!"
I'm going to miss those laughs. Oh.
Rowan has been such a character.
I'm sorry to see him go
because he is so ambitious
and so imaginative and he puts
so much thought into this baking.
He delivered a showstopper which
was very impressive to look at,
but it just didn't taste good.
Going to miss you, Rowan.
Such mixed emotions.
Sad for Rowan, ecstatic for Marc
because he really deserved
and needed that for his confidence.
I just got star baker, didn't I?
On Bread Week.
It's the thing that I enjoy making,
it's the thing that started me
on this whole baking experience.
To get star baker, that is amazing.
Well done, Marc. Thank you.
It was good, it was really good.
Marc E did really
well in the signature,
pretty well in the technical as well
and in the showstopper,
he managed to get his dough risen
and tasting good,
so the whole Buddhist ethos
really worked for him.
Hey! Well done for getting star
baker.
Thank you very much.
Hey, Gibbygibs.
Thank you, girls.
Love you. I love you too.
You're the best. Thank you.
Oh, you've made me
get all emotional now.
Next time... Oh, my God.
It's Chocolate Week. Sweet.
And there's tension in the tent...
Oh, come on.
..as the bakers face a
nerve-wracking signature.
Don't drop, don't drop, don't drop.
It's a waiting game as they prove
themselves...
High five. There you go.
..In a tough technical.
Never heard of one.
I wish I knew what it looked like.
And the temperature rises...
It's starting to really heat
up in here now.
..with a triple-tiered showstopper
which will lead to one of the bakers
coming off the tracks.
We're getting hammered.
Ruthless.
Subtitles by Red Bee Media
http://Scene-RLS.net